get ready for another heated supreme
court battle liberal justice stephen
breyer will be retiring this summer at
the end of the high court's current term
the huge news leaking out before breyer
could officially announce it himself
multiple sources tell shen bream that
the justice was surprised with how this
played out
but president biden and his white house
claim they don't know anything about it
there has been no announcement from
justice breyer let him make whatever
statement he's going to make and i'll be
happy to talk about it later the
president has
stated and reiterated his commitment to
nominating a black woman to the supreme
court and certainly
stands by that
for today again i'm just not going to
be able to say anything about
any specifics until of course justice
breyer makes any announcement should he
decide to make an announcement democrats
are reportedly looking at ramming
through biden's eventual nominee and
follow a similar timeline that
republicans used for amy coney barrett
the white house confirming biden's
looking at a woman of color to fill the
role while getting pressed on who he may
pick
is there any scenario in which the
president would select his vice
president kamala harris for the supreme
court
again i'm not going to speak to any
considerations preparations lists just
wondering hypothetically theoretically
would someone who was an attorney
general of a large state and who served
with many key senate votes be an
attractive candidate to the president
for an open supreme court seat i see
what you did there peter but the
president has every intention as he said
before of running free of reelection and
for running for re-election with uh vice
president harris on the ticket as his
partner
so what would motivate
a leak
right before breyer announces possibly
from the white house well this is super
high stakes and one of my favorite
things to do is cover a supreme court
nomination so i was quite excited today
when i heard about this um obviously
breyer has had a long career
in the judiciary not only in the supreme
court but before and so this decision
it's such high stakes for any sort of
president i think in a
now there is reporting that says his
decision to announce was imminent and
that the white house maybe jumped the
gun by a hare or somebody at the white
house did or maybe not the white house
i understand why because they have a lot
of work to do you got to get everybody
in line now what did we report this
morning on america's newsroom that biden
is losing in the polls even with
democrats
so what is one thing that can focus the
mind and that is a supreme court
nomination now because the filibuster
rules had changed and you can get to a
supreme court vote with 51 votes now
it's not as big a deal but they only
have 51 votes right 50 plus kamala
harris
the white house has also said it's going
to be a judge the president has said on
the campaign trail it's going to be a
black woman so you could look at how
many judges there are and i would
imagine you probably could figure out
their names pretty quickly that list
will come will narrow down uh
senator schumer might not be the
majority leader after the november
midterms so they had to do this right
away if they waited until the end of the
term which was in the in end of june
that would only have given them four
months and i think a lot of people
including somebody like even like
pearson cinema or joe manchin could have
said you know what we ought to wait yeah
we ought to wait and see this way they
can try to get it done right away and
now i guess the the nominee has to go
through mansion and some uh some a
little bit right yeah and they hold a
lot of cards i'm with dana this is
fantastic i uh you know immediately you
think okay this is the best news joe's
ever heard because he needs a historical
poc right
who's just hanging around driving him
nuts right now it's like he can unload
the lemon and the lemon gets a promotion
i mean that's amazing
but i don't know if it's going to do it
because it's such an obvious ploy i
think that merrick garland should come
out and identify as a non-binary person
of color and see and become a historical
first but i'll tell you this whoever
gets nominated
i'm going to say that that person be
they male or female or non-binary did
something really bad to me a long time
ago i'm not going to say what it is that
they did to me can you remember
it might have been i don't know yet it
might be college it might have been like
high school might have been in the gym
who knows but i'm going to tell you
whatever i say is going to be 100 true
and disgusting and i would prefer if you
guys just respected my privacy
when this happens um but the thing is
the question is will the republicans be
as disgusting and partisan and
vindictive
as the dems were on basically every
single nominee and i don't believe two
wrongs make a right but boy it's gonna
feel good i would rather have two wrongs
sometimes two wrongs are better than a
right and in this case i think that i
want an explosive hearing with corrupt
lawyers freaky shrinks the return of
just jessica or julie swetnick got to
get avenatti on like a zoom call for
jail uh we and i'm gonna get my i'm
gonna go and get my handmaid's costume
out of storage and i'm gonna wear
you know what greg as much as we all
want to see that i don't think that's
going to happen geraldo do you see this
happening the way it would be if that
had happened and i also call on
republicans right now to be gracious to
the nominee
it's going to go through no matter what
you do gracious be gracious don't be
like the democrats don't torture
the nominee i thought that kamala harris
would be a great idea is the first name
that jumped into my mind she could be a
terrific supreme court justice an
appointment for life she's only in her
50s she'd be there for 30 years
i think she'd be attributed
[Laughter]
that was also true but you know but it's
a it's a role fit for her but a lifelong
appointment it's a role
it's not gonna happen uh they you know
they've already put out the uh you know
the uh the dc circuit judge uh
brown jackson the south carolina
district judge michelle childs uh
leondra cougar all black women it's
interesting that it's absolutely it's
definitely affirmative action right as
they are considering the affirmative
action the seminal affirmative action
case against harvard and the university
of north carolina so it is it is ironic
yeah uh it is ironic but i'm all for
targeted uh you know there is no black
woman on the court why not uh do it uh
and that republicans behave what about a
puerto rican they have one so you can't
have more why not more geraldo yes
but much more judge she is my favorite
judge
she's the one who gave me disinformation
on 100 000
here's the thing there is this is coming
at such an opportune time for joe biden
the distraction is perfect for him his
numbers are in the tank you know now
everybody knows supreme court hearing
nominee hearing we can get crazy we can
go lunatic live tv and you know what and
it is live tv but i have to tell you
geraldo i'm tired of the republicans you
know playing by the marcus of queenberry
rules i'm tired of that i'm not saying
you have to be an animal about it but
darn let's just let people know we got a
slap in there too when we can do it and
not everybody is perfectly clean and not
every and you know you see a republican
slap a black woman around that's going
to be great come on you know what i'm
talking about i'm talking about
figuratively what they did to kavanaugh
and what they did to amy coney barrett
it was outrageous and in the end what
americans want is a judge who is justice
who is competent who is smart and who is
non-political we don't want politics in
the united states supreme court and you
know what if you want to pick a woman of
color that's fine but just make sure
she's competent and there are no
circumstances you had your say this is
my turn i'm sorry okay
so right now you've got confident judges
you've got judge jackson you've got
justice krueger you've got several of
them who've already got senate
confirmation so it won't be that bad and
you're right 50 plus one that's all they
need kirsten cinema and joe manchin have
voted for every judicial nominee that
biden has put forward already all right
oh all right
and the judge says the republicans can
play dirty so there you go i need a baby
there you go you've been given
permission by judge jeanine don't do it
like they have a backbone and whatever
goes with that all right what goes with
that i'm having an article uh published
in the new yorker it'll be written by uh
ronan farrow where did she touch you uh
i can't i'm gonna show you on the doll
[Laughter]
we're gonna do that in the break hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else